>> Bret: 11 LONDON, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IN THIS COUNTRY
PRESIDENT TRUMP INVITED HOUSE
DEMOCRATS TO LUNCH TODAY,
ESSENTIALLY GOING OVER THE HEAD
OF HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI.
NONE OF THEM SHOWED UP.
HIS LATEST EFFORT TO GET
DEMOCRATS TO THE TABLE TO TALK
ABOUT THE FUNDING FOR A BORDER
BARRIER OR WALL AND TRIED TO
FIND AN END TO THE GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN.
JOHN ROBERTS HAS WHAT HAPPENS
NOW.
>> WHAT HAPPENS NOW IS THE WILL
CONTINUE TO TRY TO APPEAL TO
MODERATE DEMOCRATS ON HIS CALLS
FOR MONEY FOR BORDER SECURITY,
INCLUDING BUILDING A BARRIER, AN
EFFORT TO DO THAT FELT THE DAY
WHEN TWO OF THE COCHAIRS OF THE
COALITION AND SOME OF THE
DEMOCRATS SAID TO THE PRESIDENT,
THANKS, BUT NO THANKS.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP INVITED A
HANDFUL OF DEMOCRATS TO THE
WHITE HOUSE TODAY ALONG WITH AN
EQUAL NUMBER OF REPUBLICANS TO
TALK BORDER SECURITY.
NONE OF THE DEMOCRATS TOOK HIM
UP ON THE OFFER.
>> I THINK IT IS PRETTY TELLING.
THIS WAS SUPPOSED TO BE A
BIPARTISAN LUNCH, NOT A SINGLE
DEMOCRAT WAS ABLE TO SHOW UP
THAT IS PRETTY TELLING.
>> THE LUNCH REINFORCED THE
MANTRA THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
WILLING TO CUT A DEAL, BUT THE
DEMOCRATS ONLY WANT TO OBSTRUCT.
ON CAPITOL HILL, CHUCK SCHUMER
INSISTED THAT HE IS GOING TO
TALK ANYTIME AND ANYWHERE.
>> WILL MEET WITH HIM ANYTIME HE
WANTS, THE LAST TIME I SPOKE
WITH HIM WAS WHEN HE WALKED OUT.
HE THREW A TEMPER TANTRUM AND HE
WALKED OUT.
WE HAVEN'T HEARD FROM THEM SINCE
THEN.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP TROLLED A
HOUSE SPEAKER ON TWITTER TODAY
WRITING "WHY IS NANCY PELOSI
GETTING BIG AND PEOPLE WHO ARE
WORKING OR NOT?"
SHE TOLD HIM RIGHT BACK IN A
TWEET SAYING, "STOP HOLDING THE
PAYCHECKS FOR 800,000         80
PAYCHECKS FOR 800,000         8A
PAYCHECKS FOR 800,000         8E
PAYCHECKS FOR 800,000         8I
PAYCHECKS FOR 800,000         8A
PAYCHECKS FOR 800,000         8S
HOSTAGE."
REOPEN THE GOVERNMENT.
REPUBLICANS ACCUSED DEMOCRATS OF
IGNORING NATIONAL SECURITY JUST
TO STICK IT TO THE PRESIDENTS.
>> WHILE THEY ALL OF THE SUDDEN
FLIP-FLOPPED ON THIS ISSUE?
THE ANSWER IS PRETTY CLEAR, THIS
IS NOW AN IDEA THAT COMES FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE
DEMOCRATS CLEARLY DON'T WANT TO
GIVE THE PRESIDENT AND VICTORY
ON THIS ISSUE.
>> THE LINGERING EFFECT OF THE
SHUTDOWN TOOK ON NEW
SIGNIFICANCE TODAY, THE
COAST GUARD TWEETING TO HIS
COSTUDIES, TODAY YOU WILL NOT BE
RECEIVING YOUR REGULAR SCHEDULED
PAYCHECK, TO THE BEST OF MY
KNOWLEDGE THIS MARKS THE FIRST
TIME IN OUR NATION'S HISTORY
THAT SERVICE MEMBERS IN THE U.S.
ARMED FORCES NOT BEEN PAID
DURING A LAPSE IN APPROPRIATION.
WITH TAXES AND APPROACHING COME
THE TREASURY DEPARTMENT
ANNOUNCED IT WOULD CALL BACK
MORE THAN HALF OF THE IRS AND
THEIR WORKFORCE LATER THIS MONTH
WITHOUT PAY TO HANDLE TAX
REFUNDS.
THE AGENCY MAY STILL NOT BE ABLE
TO FULFILL SOME KEY FUNCTIONS.
>> WHILE ALL SIDES CLAIM THEY
WANT TO END THE SHUTDOWN, THERE
IS NO MOVEMENT TOWARDS
COMPROMISE.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO SEE PROPOSALS
GOING BACK AND FORTH EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
>> DEMOCRATS BELIEVE THEY CAN
SIMPLY CLICK PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
A SHUTDOWN BEGINS TO FIGHT.
>> YOU ARE NOT WINNING THE FIGH
FIGHT.
YOU MAY BE IN YOUR OWN UNTRUTH
BUBBLE, BUT YOU ARE NOT WINNING
THE FIGHT.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP CONTINUES A
PLAN TO CONTINUE TO INVITE OVER
MODERATE DEMOCRATS TO THE
WHITE HOUSE TO TALK TO THEM
ABOUT THE NEED FOR BORDER
SECURITY TOMORROW, HE MAY HAVE
MEMBERS OVER WITH THE PROBLEM
SOLVERS CAUCUS, WE'RE NOT SURE
IF THAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN.
AS TODAY ABOUT THE EFFECT OF THE
DEMOCRATS SHOWN THE DEMOCRATS  T
DEMOCRATS SHOWN THE DEMOCRATS  O
DEMOCRATS SHOWN THE DEMOCRATS  M
DEMOCRATS SHOWN THE DEMOCRATS  K
DEMOCRATS SHOWN THE DEMOCRATS  E
PRESIDENTS, IF THE PRESIDENT